[Musique]
voilà donc je vous réitère toutes nos
excuses pour ce
c'est important décalage mais bon comme
on a eu des auditions qui sont succédées
passionnantes et qui ont suscité
beaucoup de questions et qu'on a
commencé déjà avec un peu de retard donc
inévitablement quand on arrive en fin de
d'après-midi en fin de journée c'est
vous qui en êtes malheureusement le plus
pénalisé donc nous sommes heureux de
poursuivre les travaux de notre
commission d'enquête avec cette table
ronde sur l'innovation et des startups
dans le secteur de la rénovation
énergétique je relève qu'on parle de
protect pour désigner les entreprises
qui utilisent de façon innovante les
technologies dans les secteurs de
l'immobilier et de la construction donc
nous recevons donc les représentants de
trois organismes Monsieur Hervé charrue
directeur général adjoint recherche et
développement du Centre Scientifique et
Technique du Bâtiment le CSTB vous vous
occupez donc de suivre les questions de
recherche au sein de cet établissement
public chargé de diffuser et de
valoriser les connaissances
scientifiques et techniques en matière
de construction et d'habitat notamment
pour les procédés et les matériaux
monsieur Christophe Philippe ponot
directeur général de tipi votre
entreprise est située à la Gordes à la
limite de la Rochelle dans le parc
Atlantique qui est le premier quartier
urbain bacarbonne de France elle cherche
à être un chaînon manquant entre la
recherche scientifique et l'application
industrielle et se veut ainsi la
première plateforme technologique du
bâtiment durable qui forme qui conseille
et qui accompagne des professionnels de
la construction grâce à des solutions
innovantes et Monsieur Nicolas Durand
fondateur et président directeur général
de cozinergies votre entreprise elle est
située à Toulouse et elle s'est dotée de
13 agences locales elle propose en
partenariat avec des établissements
bancaires et vos succéder à deux
établissements bancaires le Crédit
Mutuel la Banque Postale
un accompagnement de bout en bout des
particuliers qui souhaitent initier des
travaux de rénovation énergétique de
leur logement du bilan de l'existant au
suivi des travaux en passant par la
préconisation des actes de rénovation
les devis la demande puis l'obtention
des aides et des subventions
messieurs la rénovation énergétique des
logements peine à atteindre les
objectifs ambitieux que nous ne sommes
fixés depuis un certain nombre d'années
alors que le calendrier s'accélère les
technologies innovantes peuvent sans
aucun doute améliorer l'efficacité des
conditions dans lesquelles les travaux
de rénovation sont conduits c'est
pourquoi nous attendons de vous de nous
apporter aujourd'hui un éclairage
percutant sur les solutions d'avenir en
matière de rénovation énergétique le
financement de la recherche reste
problématique dans la filière bâtiment
et construction puisqu'il est
extrêmement faible il représente
seulement pour le secteur privé environ
0,1 à 0,2 % des 130 milliards d'euros du
chiffre d'affaires du secteur en dépit
de cette triste réalité quelles
opportunités peuvent donc offrir la
recherche et les innovations
technologiques en termes de
décarbonation et d'efficacité
énergétique comment les entreprises qui
utilisent de façon innovante les
technologies dans le secteur de la
construction peuvent-elles aider à
relever le défi de la massification et
de l'accélération des rénovations de
logement quel regard portez-vous sur les
objectifs et les moyens de la rénovation
énergétique des logements en France
jugez-vous les dispositifs de soutien à
la rénovation énergétique des logements
pertinents et efficace
et quelles évolutions estimez-vous
nécessaires voilà avant de vous laisser
la parole pour répondre à ces premières
questions et je doute pas qu'il y en
aura d'autres de la part du rapporteur
ou très savatement de notre collègue
présente à cette audition il me revient
de vous indiquer que cette audition est
diffusée en direct et en différé sur le
site internet du Sénat et qu'un
compte-rendu sera publié je dois
également vous rappeler qu'un faux
témoignage devant notre commission
d'enquête serait passible des peines
prévues aux articles
434-13
434-14 et
434-15 du code pénal qui peuvent aller
de trois ans à 7 ans d'emprisonnement et
de 45000 euros à 100000 euros d'amende
je vous invite donc à prêter serment de
dire toute la vérité rien que la vérité
a levé la main droite et à dire je le
jure
et bien je vous remercie je vous laisse
la parole pour répondre déjà à cette
première question dans l'ordre que vous
le souhaitez on peut peut-être commencer
par Monsieur charrue et ensuite
continuer tel que vous êtes installé
dans cette salle merci beaucoup merci
Madame président donc le faible niveau
de financement c'est quelque chose de
récur c'est d'ailleurs une étude que
l'on a faite dans le cadre de l'encre
sur l'effort de R&D du secteur savait
amené à finaliser ces chiffres et la
stabiliser alors moi je commencerai par
un aphorisme d'un commissaire européen
anglais je pense qui en questionnait sur
le niveau de la fois technicité de
besoin de R&D et il avait dit oui
donc ça y est c'est terminé il avait
fermé un petit peu l'espoir qu'il y
avait dans ce secteur là une véritable
problématique de recherche
alors cette problématique elle est
toujours pas perçue mais je pense qu'il
y a un vrai changement depuis je dirais
la mise en série des problématiques qui
sont associés d'abord d'une part
d'énergie on a beaucoup travaillé sur
l'énergie mais c'est surtout par le
chaînage des problématiques qui sont
associés évidemment un bâtiment dans
lequel on vit il y a une problématique
énergétique qui est associée le carbone
qui est arrivé très récemment mais bien
avant il y a eu les problèmes des
problématiques sanitaires donc les
qualités d'air intérieures qui ont été
mises un peu plus sur le devant de la
scène avec l'histoire du covid donc ça
permet de penser que tous les enjeux de
recherche ce n'est pas que une
succession de problématiques liée à la
maîtrise du risque stabilité des
structures les maîtrise que du risque
incendie la maîtrise que la maîtrise de
la consolation de l'énergie la qualité
de l'air est ainsi de suite c'est leur
interopération et ces sujets sont
complexes d'ailleurs le CNRS qui est
surtout un acteur
thématique scientifiques effectivement
non l'interopérante ou armes
interopérante la problématique est
arrivée avec la transisciplinarité
d'arriver à chêné toutes ces questions
et tous ces sujets scientifiques entre
eux pour voir quel impact va avoir le
fait dans l'application propre au
bâtiment typiquement on va voir si je
fais une rénovation énergétique et que
j'oublie la qualité de l'air sur la
ventilation le contrôle hygrométrique
j'aurais des problèmes sanitaires si je
fais la nation énergétique sans penser
au fait que par exemple avec une
isolation par l'extérieur dans un
bâtiment collectif je vais avoir une
réémergence des de l'acoustique
interlobat bâtiment donc une gêne au
niveau du confort qui va créer des
problèmes sanitaires notamment
cardiopathie au niveau des expositions
longues donc il y a une prise en compte
qui se fait de plus en plus aujourd'hui
bon néanmoins ça ne se traduit pas dans
les chiffres au sens de la R&D
tant par les financements publics
d'évoluent à ce secteur-là le CSTB dans
ce cadre là il a une stabilité de sa
subvention publique qui doit être de
l'ordre de 15 millions 7 depuis
plusieurs années depuis moins de 5 ans
et évidemment les enjeux qui se sur
ajoutent et qui sont ceux qui sont
arrivés notamment avec le carbone et la
l'économie circulaire
[Musique]
le problème qui a aussi c'est que nous
n'avons pas comme notre secteur
d'intégrateur donc il n'y a pas un
acteur qui a la responsabilité globale
dans l'automobile nous constructeur
automobile se retrouve à la charge à la
fois de la logique performance
du véhicule puisqu'on a beaucoup évolué
maintenant vers une logique service ciel
un bâtiment aujourd'hui quand il est
livré vous avez soit un promoteur soit
un gestionnaire qui a fabriqué le
bâtiment mais tous les acteurs qui sont
intervenus ont leur correspond ici la
responsabilité propre dans la
performance qui est mesurée ou pas
d'ailleurs et donc le fait qu'il n'y ait
pas d'intégrateur ne pousse pas avoir
une recherche intégrée qui permettent de
gérer toutes ces interopérations donc ça
c'est un vrai sujet et la filière
a aussi à travers ces grands équilibres
qu'on a essayé de conserver entre les
différentes matériaux notamment entre le
béton entre le briquet de Mokhtar centre
l'acier entre le bois
ce sont des systèmes qui étaient assez
mono matériaux et qui maintenant
commence avec la mise en oeuvre des
probatiques carbone et environnement à
se dire que effectivement il faut
utiliser le bon matériau au bon endroit
pour la bonne performance et que les
synergies et un terme matériaux
commencent à se faire jour et donc vont
nécessiter de plus en plus de recherche
et notamment par les interfaces puisque
les problématiques de recherche dans
toutes les questions qui sont à traiter
sur le sujet du bâtiment se situe
toujours aux interfaces et c'est là en
plus que généralement les acteurs étant
différents mon intégré il y a peu de
recherches qui se fait entre les deux
donc le CSTB en fait le CNRS s'en fait
le CEVA en fait mais on est quand même
sur une logique d'approche multisystème
qui n'a pas encore percollé au sens
général du terme donc voilà ce qui
explique à mon avis mais ça dure déjà
depuis longtemps et les orientations ne
sont pas quand on regarde les dépenses à
l'échelle européenne qui sont soit sur
la santé soit sur le transport
sur la recherche sur le bâtiment c'est
ça reste toujours le pas en pauvre en
terme d'investissement à l'année
il est difficile de passer après
moi je pense qu'il y a véritablement
déjà je crois qu'il faut prendre
conscience que le monde du bâtiment un
monde de l'artisanat
on a quand même plus sur les 425 selon
des chiffres de la FFB de 2021 sur 427
000 entreprises du bâtiment il y en a
403000 qui ont moins de 10 salariés donc
la recherche par rapport à ces personnes
là c'est compliqué pour moi je viens
d'une entreprise avant beaucoup plus
grosse que cela mais malgré tout je
n'avais pas cette logique d'aller me
faire accompagner d'aller développer
je considère que la bonne idée elle
était celle du terrain et j'avais pas
besoin de la faire valider et je vois
nous ce que l'on a fait avec la
plateforme tipi ça a été justement de se
dire il faut qu'on soit entre guillemets
un traducteur une interface entre ce
monde de la recherche d'accord et ce
monde de leur petite entreprise qui ne
se parle pas et de se côtoient pas
et effectivement créer ce lien là et on
voit bien que c'est un système qui
marche puisque on a de nombreuses
petites entreprises ou de petits
créateurs de startups qui viennent nous
voir pour qu'on les accompagne pour
mettre en oeuvre ce que j'appelle moi
d'une idée de fond de garage en faire
une innovation performante et économique
sans cette aide là sans cette structure
là il n'y arriverait pas et on a de
belles réussites déjà dans ce cadre là
en développant de nouveaux produits en
partant de l'innovation la capacité
d'innovation je dirais
inconnu même de la personne qui l'a
d'accord donc ça je pense que c'est
quelque chose qu'il faut bien prendre
conscience et qu'il faut si on veut
réussir dans l'innovation et faire
évoluer notre filière par l'innovation
il faut qu'on ça on s'occupe de ces gens
qui ont des bonnes idées sur le terrain
et pour les mettre en valeur ça pour moi
c'est vraiment la première chose qui est
qui est importante
ensuite effectivement je crois que on a
aussi une difficulté c'est que on a une
culture dans le bâtiment qui est une
culture métier par métier
et qu'on voit bien aujourd'hui que y
compris est principalement dans la
rénovation si on n'a pas une vision
systémique si on avait pas une vision
transverse c'est très compliqué
d'arriver à des choses performantes
aujourd'hui on a eu beaucoup d'aide on
commence beaucoup plus à parler de
Google de rénovation globale mais au
départ on faisait des spots on faisait
des siestes de rénovation et on voyait
bien là qu'il y a ça marchait pas donc
je pense qu'on a aussi un besoin c'est
de pouvoir entre guillemets donner à
l'ensemble de nos professionnels qui
sont des très bons professionnels dans
leur métier des visions aussi
transverses d'impact de leur action pour
qu'on puisse avoir des visions 3 ce que
j'appelle moins 360 degrés et là aussi
on voit bien que c'est là aussi
l'évolution qu'on va avoir
des métiers puisque vous avez très
facilement dès que vous faites de la
construction neuve vous avez un
architecte vous allez mettre d'ouvrage
et de sa fin à mettre d'oeuvre etc en
rénovation pas forcément et donc si vous
n'avez pas cette personne cette
tiers de confiance que j'allais dire qui
est capable lui d'avoir une vision
transverses et accompagner à tout le
monde dans cette évolution et du respect
de des gestes des autres c'est un des
problématiques qu'on va avoir aussi et
également à résoudre et je pense que
c'est pour moi une grande partie des
raisons pour lesquelles on ne peut pas
dire que nos opérations de rénovation
dans les dernières années étaient des
dernières nations par formente d'accord
parce qu'elles étaient des gestes n'ont
pas des rénovations des rénovations
globales donc ça je pense que vraiment
là là aussi il faut vraiment avoir une
formation il faut vraiment avoir mise en
place des éléments qui nous permettent
d'avoir ces personnes qui vont et je
crois que mon voisin à côté bon c'est un
peu la tasse de thé mais véritablement
avoir cette notion là
la troisième chose pour moi pour réunir
la rénovation on parle de massification
alors massification moi j'y crois
beaucoup mais elle est sa petite a une
petite échelle quand j'entends une
petite échelle c'est que pour moi c'est
l'effet papillon c'est c'est de se dire
si je fais une massification de la
rénovation à l'échelle
d'une commune
d'une d'un quartier etc je peux
embarquer un maximum de monde alors
quand je parle de massification c'est la
massification en Réno et je reviendrai
après sur la capacité industrielle mais
je crois également beaucoup dans le fait
de l'effet dans
d'engagement des uns vis-à-vis des
autres
vous m'avez cité comme directeur général
de tipee mais je suis également
président du cLOSTER de
l'éco-construction durable en
nouvelle-aquitaine et Fada un peu de
problématique de rénovation et on a mené
quelques actions qui étaient de se dire
on va essayer d'avoir des dynamiques
communales de rénovation c'est je suis
maire d'une commune je m'engage à faire
de la rénovation et je vais en même
temps en faire un projet citoyen
d'accord et on s'aperçoit on s'aperçoit
qu'effectivement on a un engagement qui
se fait des citoyens qui lorsqu'on le
voit son voisin améliorer son habitat y
compris par du visuel parce qu'il faut
pas oublier non plus une chose c'est que
la source de motivation pour se lancer
dans la rénovation elle est pas
seulement économique
elle est aussi patrimoine elle est aussi
ma qualité de vie que je vais avoir etc
le confort l'usage que je vais en tirer
d'accord et il faut pas que l'argument
soit uniquement l'argument économie
d'énergie parce que on part de très loin
moi je me rappelle de campagne
présidentielle alors je rappelle parce
que j'ai vu je me rappelle les images de
74 où il y avait l'électricité qui
arrivait qui allait libéré la femme des
stages ménagères c'est 74 d'accord et
bien si vous commencez à dire aux gens
je vais vous priver d'électricité ou
fafare les économies intrinsèquement
dans sa tête c'est la privation donc il
faut compenser par d'autres gains pour
qu'il puisse l'engagement là je faisais
une diversion mais voilà et donc je
pense véritablement que et on le voit et
bien dans une commune où il y a un
engagement collectif où on commence à
avoir une dynamique
collective autour de ce projet là et
bien il y a des gens qui n'avaient pas
pensé y aller qui vont y aller puisque
si mon voisin l'a fait je suis capable
de le faire d'accord vous me parliez du
du parc bas carbone c'est là que je suis
aussi directeur de l'association qui est
en charge l'amén agement du parc ba
carbone de La Rochelle et je peux et je
participe au consortium de La Rochelle
territoire 0 carbone et bien c'est la
dynamique qu'on veut créer c'est la
dynamique qui est de se dire on va
prendre des échelles où les gens se
reconnaissent de telle manière à engager
cette procédure
et c'est pour ça que je parle de
massification c'est la massification de
l'envie de faire
après effectivement je pense c'est comme
le disait monsieur charrue avant on a
une autre problématique c'est qu'il faut
impérativement qu'on arrive à avoir que
quelque soit l'opérateur ou garantit un
minimum qualitatif de la rénovation et
ça je pense que c'est pas effectivement
l'industrialisation des process qu'on va
pouvoir y arriver des produits d'accord
sans oublier sans enlever qu'on est
quand même à chaque fois dans un
bâtiment différent etc et donc avoir un
professionnel qui soit capable de le
mettre en oeuvre donc voilà les grands
messages moi que j'ai là-dessus c'est
effectivement massification mais à
l'échelle humaine on va dire cela comme
ça
développer des intérêts qui vont au-delà
de l'économie d'énergie mais bien
développé tous les produits annexes tous
les gains annexes que l'on peut avoir
et puis passer de on peut faire le tout
ce qu'on peut faire le qui peut le plus
peu loin et bien non c'est aujourd'hui
c'est le juste besoin pour permettre
d'arriver à ce genre de choses donc
voilà le message que vous voulez faire
passer merci pour ces premiers propos
monsieur Durand
bonsoir mettez votre micro s'il vous
plaît
bonsoir à tous
du coup
concernant la rénovation énergétique
avant on parlait de rénovation puis venu
rénovation énergétique c'est quelque
chose qui reste encore assez récent je
pense qu'une vingtaine d'années
rapprocher le micro on vous entend pas
très bien voilà merci
je disais que au départ on parlait de
rénovation ensuite est venu la notion de
rénovation énergétique c'est quelque
chose qui qui reste assez récent et puis
on parle de plus en plus de rénovation
énergétique globale parce qu'on se rend
compte qu'en fait c'est la rénovation
énergétique globale qui est celle qui a
la performance en fait voilà donc
ce sont des choses qu'on que voilà que
tout le monde tout le monde dit mais
c'est vrai que la pratique elle est
encore assez loin de cette rénovation
énergétique globale malheureusement
donc lorsque ce que j'ai créé cause
énergie il y a une dizaine d'années
l'idée c'était de se positionner à la
place de d'un client un particulier qui
a une maison individuelle et qui se dit
voilà j'ai besoin de faire des économies
d'énergie
à qui je peux m'adresser comment je peux
faire et là en fait c'est vrai que c'est
logique de se dire bah il faudrait
d'abord faire un bilan énergétique pour
se rendre compte un petit peu de
où on est comment on est classé et
ensuite voir sur quoi on peut travailler
alors est-ce que l'étiquette énergie
elle va nous indiquer certaines choses
après il faut que techniquement on voit
ce qui est possible et est-ce qu'il est
pas parce que on peut dire effectivement
il faut faire l'isolation sur ce
bâtiment mais si on est par exemple sur
le bâtiment dans lequel on est on va
avoir un certain nombre de contraintes
donc voilà donc il y a ce mix après
thermique technique
et puis après il va y avoir le
financement de cette rénovation voilà
qu'est-ce qu'on peut se permettre de
faire est-ce qu'il y a de dispositif
pour le faire et on se rend compte que
c'est parce que c'est relativement
complexe mais par contre c'est important
de faire une rénovation énergétique
globale voilà donc
l'exemple que
les personnes qu'on a le que les
particuliers le réflexe de recevoir dans
ces cas-là c'est quelqu'un qui va
intervenir sur un lot généralement soit
un lot de chauffage soit un lot
d'isolation
et quand on prend par exemple l'exemple
du chauffage on va se rendre compte que
le chauffagiste il vient il va devoir
dimensionner son système de chauffage
par rapport à une déperdition de
thermique et du coup il va si on a une
maison qui est pas isolée de voir du
coup dimensionner une pompe à chaleur
relativement puissante la plus chère
mais ça va être sans devoir que de
dimensionner comme ça sinon il serait en
tort il aura des problématiques après de
réalisation par rapport à son assurance
etc
mais son intérêt ça va pas forcément
être d'aller dire à son client il
faudrait d'abord que vous fassiez
l'isolation et que vous reveniez me voir
dans 10 ans
voilà donc je décris un petit peu le
paysage il y a quelques années pour en
arriver après à l'innovation parce que
sur sur l'innovation dans la rénovation
énergétique c'est vrai qu'on peut mettre
d'un côté l'innovation sur les produits
qui est difficile qui coûteuse qui est
je crois plus aujourd'hui dans les mains
des grands industriels pour ensuite
aller
au CSTB ou des différents acteurs c'est
quelque chose qui est
qui se fait mais qui est pas facile en
tout cas qui est très difficile par des
startups il y a une innovation dans les
services
et
moi je connais un peu plus cette
innovation dans les services et ce que
je vous ai décrit au début cette
approche globale de la rénovation
énergétique le fait d'aller chez un
particulier de commencer par un bilan
énergétique de faire une étude ensuite
technique sur qu'est-ce qui est possible
réellement voilà est-ce que cette pompe
à chaleur peut s'installer est-ce que
cette menuisier elle veut s'installer
tout le monde ne sait pas le dire ça et
pouvoir donner un particulier quelque
chose de précis sur l'aspect thermique
sur l'aspect technique et ensuite sur
l'aspect financier moi je considère que
c'est une innovation de service qui est
pas très coûteuse mais malgré tout il a
fallu développer des logiciels pour ça
mais qui je pense mériterait d'être
déployé très largement parce que je
crois que tout le monde chaque
propriétaire aimerait savoir précisément
chez lui ce qui est possible de faire
donc
ça c'était pour parler en termes voilà
d'innovation et sur les services il y a
encore d'autres choses qui peuvent être
faites notamment sur sur le financement
je pense qu'on en parlera certainement
tout à l'heure que ce soit le
financement via les aides ou via
d'autres types de financement
et l'autre chose que je voulais mettre
en avant c'est par rapport à ce qu'il y
a aussi été dit par les messieurs
charrue et Monsieur Philippot concernant
l'intégrateur ou concernant les acteurs
qui vont faire intervenir
des installateurs sur chacun des corps
de métiers donc là il y a un vrai sujet
par rapport par rapport à cette
rénovation globale et au fait que
aujourd'hui peu de personnes sont
capacité de la porter mais
dans la construction de maison
individuelle et arriver à un moment
donné le statut de constructeur de
maison individuelle avec des contrats
dédiés et avec un client même pour le
particulier aujourd'hui dans la
rénovation énergétique globale
ça n'existe pas vraiment le statut de
contractant général alors ça peut
exister donc cause énergie en fait
partie mais je crois qu'on est moins
d'une centaine d'acteurs qui avons un
RGE
contractant général rénovation
énergétique globale
et ce RGE rénovation énergétique globale
il nous sert à rien
alors je suis un peu dur de dire ça mais
dans tous les dispositifs de subventions
il est pas reconnu
pour un particulier
d'avoir une assurance de contractant
général en plus de l'assurance de
l'installateur qui va être le
sous-traitant l'intervenant c'est pas
reconnu
en fait dans le dispositif
accompagnateur rénov
un Contractant Général il est pas
reconnu non plus il va devoir choisir
est-ce que je choisis d'être contracté
en général ou est-ce que je choisis
d'être accompagnateur énervant en parler
maître d'oeuvre accompagnateur
en fait depuis 10 ans en entretien ou un
statut qui me semble très important et
on essaie de faire exister cette filière
de rénovateur ou de
contractant général de la rénovation
énergétique ou de ensemble il y a de la
rénovation énergétique mais c'est un
statut qui est pas reconnu
le seul qui est reconnu aujourd'hui
c'est l'installateur de chauffage
l'installateur d'isolation le menuisier
voilà séduire et je veux par
qualification celui-là il est pas
reconnu
et moi je c'est vrai que voilà ça c'est
un point que je voulais vraiment porter
à votre intention je sais qu'il y a des
initiatives en cours donc il y a un
appel à projet qui qui va être lancé sur
l'ensemble il y a de la rénovation
énergétique probablement que causes
énergies avec
le soutien du Groupe BPCE
se positionnera en tout cas regardera de
près ce qui peut être fait sur cet
ensemble de la rénovation énergétique
avec des solutions de financement la
rénovation énergétique derrière mais
[Musique]
je trouve que c'est surprenant que un
acteur qui est capable de proposer
clairement de la rénovation énergétique
particulier ne soit pas forcément connu
du grand public et que la tendance soit
plutôt à découper entre un auditeur qui
va faire un bilan énergétique
ensuite un coffrac qui va contrôler ce
bilan énergétique ensuite un
accompagnateur rénov qui va venir
packager le financement ensuite 2 3 4
entreprises qui vont intervenir pour
faire les travaux un accompagnateur
énorme qui va venir regarder si les
travaux ils ont été bien fait un coffrac
qui va venir contrôler si la subvention
elle est bien éligible
j'ai pas parlé encore du financeur parce
qu'il faut bien sûr financer et ça ça va
être encore un autre sujet voilà
merci monsieur le rapporteur oui merci
madame la Présidente merci pour vos
interventions
donc peut-être pour rebondir sur ce qui
vient d'être dit oui ma première
question mais vous y avez un peu répondu
c'était le comment vous voyez juste le
rôle de la compagnateur Renov par
rapport à ce que ce que vous faites en
fait et est-ce que vous avez proposé ce
que vous avez mis au point alors pour te
dire c'est vrai que nous on a encore un
peu du mal à voir réellement ce que va
être accompagnateur rénov parce que en
fonction des différentes auditions des
différents acteurs qu'on a pu avoir on
n'a pas forcément la même
description on va dire entre
l'accompagnement moteur Renov qui serait
vraiment on va dire une maîtrise
d'oeuvre quoi et qui ferait la totalité
du suivi etc et
mais derrière un coup important non
négligeable
ou juste effectivement quelqu'un qui est
sur l'administratif qui va orienter et
peut-être pourquoi pas faire un contrôle
après travaux pour l'instant c'est
quelque chose sur lequel on n'a pas eu
de monde encore à voir
que ça pose des vraies questions à la
fois financières parce que ben voilà
quel type de prestation et c'est vrai
qu'on nous a annoncé entre des
prestations à 350 200 euros et puis des
prestations qui pouvaient la 2000 €
c'est pas la même chose c'est pas le
même exigence derrière donc voilà pour
l'instant c'est vrai qu'on est on en est
un peu un peu là en tout cas dans les
différentes dans les différentes
auditions mais c'est vrai que ça a une
importance ensuite sur justement les
dispositifs comme vous avez mis au point
moi il y a peut-être une seule un seul
aspect sur le fait de en gros de dire
on appelle ensemble billet mais en tout
cas de dire on va prendre la totalité à
la fois du du conseil de l'orientation
ensuite les travaux le financement aussi
puisque qui sont du financement les
travaux il y a quand même la question à
un moment donné du contrôle et de
l'indépendance du contrôle donc enfin
voilà la maîtrise d'oeuvre en général
elle est indépendante justement de celui
qui fait la des travaux pour pour cette
raison là donc du coup comment vous
l'intégrez en tout cas dans votre
dispositif parce que c'est vrai que pour
avoir cette confiance
c'est intéressant d'avoir la globalité
c'est sûr enfin de se dire allez j'ai
plus rien à faire en tout cas chez
quelqu'un qui va s'occuper de tout et
sur l'ensemble de la chaîne des travaux
et des différents lots par contre c'est
vrai que peut avoir aussi cette
tentation en tout cas sur le sur le
contrôle et sur le fait de d'avoir le
même qui va être à la fois celui qui
exécute et puis si qui enfin
ma première ma première question après
plus globalement sur toutes les
questions de on va dire d'innovation et
de ce qui peut être mis en place c'est
vrai qu'il y a quand même tout un aspect
qu'on a pu voir sur sur la rénovation
thermique
sur la question aussi de du confort
d'été et donc de tous ces dispositifs
alors que ce soit en termes de matériaux
mais aussi de
de réflexion qui peut y avoir en termes
d'innovation justement pour répondre à
ces différentes questions alors à la
fois sur les questions les types de
matériaux c'était sur le sur le bâtiment
sur le patrimoine mais je te laisserai
intervenir là-dessus
mais aussi sur notamment le
développement de matériaux biosourcés
donc on sait qu'on a beaucoup de
développement sur ces questions là que
ce soit le champ de la paille etc on a
fait une table ronde sur l'ensemble de
matériaux biosourcés
avec toujours quand même une
problématique là plutôt l'ISF en tout
cas sur comment cette chaîne là ensuite
on a des avis techniques on a la
question des assurances et que pour ses
filières qui sont des petites filières
peuvent accéder à ça quoi alors ce qu'on
a l'exemple de la paille qui est plutôt
intéressant en fait qui a réussi
justement à peu près à ce à se
structurer mais je vais avoir un peu
votre votre avis là-dessus de la même
manière sur la question des normes
puisqu'on a fait aussi une table ronde
sur
sur les outre-mer et on a vu aussi que
cette question normative en tout cas et
d'harmonisation des normes entre la
réglementation européenne et puisqu'on
peut trouver dans les dans les outre-mer
mais c'est cette question-là se pose
aussi et sur les types de matériaux
également et en lien aussi avec des
pathologies du bâtiment qui peuvent être
qui peuvent être différentes donc c'est
vrai qu'il y a toutes ces questions là
en terme de en terme à la fois
d'innovation mais comment on peut
accompagner cette innovation et comment
ensuite elle peut réellement prendre
place en fait dans le circuit et en fait
elle peut vraiment être utilisé en fait
au bout du compte
voilà il y avait ce enfin moi j'avais ce
type là de ce type là de questions
peut-être je vous laisser répondre et
puis on fera
peut-être prendre une partie puisqu'on
est sur la massification de la
rénovation alors on sait que en gros
vous avez 36 millions de logements un
taux de construction neuve d'un pour
cent vous avez 26 millions de bâtiments
donc il faut rénover tout ça donc
la première
orientation qui avait été donnée c'était
plus 300 000 logements par an
puis sept ans après 500 000 et la SNBC
vient de donner plus 700 000 donc c'est
que l'équation arithmétique de dire
j'avance je pousse vraiment ce que je
n'ai pas fait donc la démonstration qui
est très simple c'est d'abord pourquoi
n'a-t-on pas fait donc on aboutit à une
première question c'est de se dire la
rénovation une finesse c'est quoi en
fait la rénovation sont 5 phases qui
sont assez structurantes et sur lequel
on a pas mal de réponses la première
c'est celle de l'identification c'est
d'avoir un constat de ce que sont les
bâtiments rénaux donc connaître
le bâtiment
aujourd'hui le cstv a développé une base
de données nationales des bâtiments dans
le cas des programmes profil
sur les C2E et ça permet d'avoir une
cartographie ressentir de tous les
bâtiments par typologie et leur niveau
avec les connaissances qui sont données
et enrichies avec les algorithmes qu'on
a développés de performances au sens du
DPE qui en plus le même recalculer
maintenant avec les nouvelles méthodes
et à partir de là ça permet d'avoir par
rapport à un projet des données de base
qui
permettent d'aller sur la phase 2 de
dire quels sont les solutions
technologiques que je vais développer
pour atteindre un niveau de performance
souhaité il est évident que il y a un
vrai questionnement est-ce que j'ai
réellement besoin de savoir précisément
si je suis ouf ou je considère qu'il y a
un gros talent qui est EFG qui est à
traiter et puis après céder et B alors
néanmoins ça veut dire que à un moment
on a besoin de connaître et de voir les
technologies qui sont déjà existantes et
là c'est comme un des sujets liés à la
recherche initialement il y a quand même
beaucoup de technologies qui existent
donc il y a-t-il besoin de technologie
supplémentaires ce dont on a souvent
besoin c'est quand même de choix
industriels c'est plutôt le vrai
problème
donc dans cette phase là on identifie en
optimise la solution la plus adaptée
pour amener un niveau de performance
donnée le bâtiment considéré et ça ça se
fait au niveau de chaque projet
troisième niveau c'est le niveau central
c'est une économie donc qui est au
niveau de la capacité à financer le
projet dans sa globalité
je n'ai pas tranché la rénovation
globale et la relation par geste ou par
phase parce qu'en fait on peut voir que
l'économiquement il y a les deux tons
sont tout à fait
légitime d'ailleurs il y en a une qui
serait préférable mais elles engagent
des financements sont très supérieurs et
le problème de l'économie il est à deux
niveaux même voire trois ou quatre le
premier c'est celui sur le projet mais
il faut sortir aussi sur les autres
échelles aujourd'hui les niveaux d'aide
que l'on donne permettent pas à des
foyers qui sont propriétaires
je dirais d'un Classe G avec faible
revenu d'arriver à faire une rénovation
qui permet d'arriver au niveau B ou
c'est ou ou encore moins
donc on voit qu'il y a un vrai sujet
faut-il les aider ou faut-il se
substituer à eux pour le faire à leur
place et après avoir ce qu'à l'époque
l'ancien président d'auspects avait
repris l'idée que j'avais donné c'était
de dire il faut faire un investissement
de l'État et on se rembourse sur les
gains avec une séparation des gains
entre un côté
usager un côté pour l'État et lors de la
mutation on récupère le différentiel du
reste
à financer à payer qui avait été financé
par l'État ça supposait d'ailleurs un
vrai sujet c'est que au niveau européen
tous les pays ont le même problème ils
ont un problème de parc identique avec
un niveau de performance identique donc
ils ont tous à rénover l'impact et je
m'étais battu à une certaine époque mais
ça n'a pas forcément donné de suite
c'était l'idée d'arriver à sortir les
effets de la rénovation énergétique des
fameux 3% de ma Street
c'est un sujet important et qui est
assujetti aussi à l'idée que on a besoin
au niveau industriel et là la recherche
a reboucle aussi sur un acier d'une
recherche qui s'organise à l'échelle
européenne pour avoir des acteurs
industriels de dimensions internationale
mais européens vous prenez la
ventilation aujourd'hui qui est un point
clé de la rénovation énergétique on
passe en toi on passe toujours aux
choses au froid mais on pense pas à la
qualité de l'air et à la gestion parce
que c'est par là que ce fait la
performance et le niveau de ventilation
et si on est bâtiments rénovés
évidemment la plupart du temps au point
d'un bâtiment haussmannien il n'a pas de
ventilation donc il faut installer
quelque chose et les acteurs actuels des
entreprises vous n'avez pas que ce soit
sur la production de froid ou de
ventilation ou autre vous n'avez pas de
leader internationaux type Daikin
Toshiba carrier ou autre qu'on a des
petits acteurs nationaux et on a donc
pas de leader européen alors j'ai
entendu bon nos voisins sur les
matériaux qui effectivement un leader
européen où il réclame quand même que
les produits sont fabriqués dans chaque
pays ce qui est une réalité parce que
soi-disant son voyage pas beaucoup donc
ce sujet de l'économie est excessivement
important parce que derrière il impacte
très fortement la capacité à financer
parce que aujourd'hui on a eu à la fois
l'effet covid qui est arrivé avec le
rocher sur les matériaux à la fois
l'effet Ukrainiens avec l'agression de
l'Ukraine qui a fait que on achète une
énergie et aujourd'hui c'est cool là ils
vont réencherrir très fortement les les
projets donc il faut arriver à les gérer
et notamment au niveau des taux
d'intérêt on se rend vite compte que
aujourd'hui il y a beaucoup de projets
qui se feront pas
le quatrième point c'est celui de la
mise en oeuvre et c'est là qu'en fait on
explique pourquoi on n'a pas fait 300
donc on a dit qu'il faudrait faire 500
qu'il faudra faire 700 c'est
qu'aujourd'hui nous n'avons pas la
capacité de réaliser les projets parce
que le secteur est en déficit je dirais
de main d'oeuvre formée ayant une
performance au sens de la mise en oeuvre
je passe même si je peux le rappeler
quand même les
non performances avant livraison sont
quand même assez importantes et
demandent à travailler en termes à la
fois d'une approche industrielle qui
assure des produits qui amènent une
performance que j'appelle le tome le
terme comme je dis n'est pas très mais
il marque bien et c'est des produits
Diop pro c'est à dire que quel que soit
le metteur en œuvre on a au moins 90% de
la performance nominale et ça c'est
vraiment très important parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a une hypersensibilité
à la mise en oeuvre pour des produits
que les industriels ne se sont pas et
vertueux à rendre
comme je dis souvent le seul qui l'a
fait c'est VELUX parce que sur les
fenêtres de toi il y avait un risque
majeur d'une sinistralité très coûteuse
donc il a travaillé la suggettissement
de la fenêtre à tout type de toiture
neuf ou rénové les gens sont formés
certifiés ils portent la garantie il
leur ramène la zone de charandies et en
un système qui fonctionne bon les
industriels de ce côté là n'ont doivent
travailler et ça c'est un vrai sujet de
recherche comment faire que les produits
dans leur intégration soit robuste dans
la performance délivrée quelle que soit
les niveaux de mise en oeuvre parce que
sur la première partie la bonne partie
précédente qui était celle liée à
l'économie le partage de la valeur
aujourd'hui il est il y a une captation
par l'industrie sur le la valeur sur les
produits donc aujourd'hui on n'a pas
d'attractivité par ce secteur pour des
emplois qui seraient rémunérés à
certains niveaux de performance ou de
compétences au sens des artisans donc on
a un véritable suivi
et c'est dans ce sujet
d'industrialisation de mise en oeuvre
qu'on doit aussi tester les solutions
les plus pertinentes donc on voit bien
qu'on a un vrai déficit de main d'oeuvre
qui n'a pas été prévu et on est bien
dans un système qui est exactement comme
le nuscule numérique clausus qui a eu
sur la santé et ça on le sait depuis
fort longtemps et il n'y a pas eu
d'orientation il est quand même le
secteur de l'éducation nationale sur la
partie enseignement cours on a une
absence de formation les gens sont ce
n'est pas attractif les salaires sont
pas attractifs on a une immigration qui
est tout à fait
peu contrôlée et pas au niveau de
performance souhaitée et donc derrière
sur la dernière partie le point 5 et
celui de la performance il faut
assujettir les
réalisations à une mesure de la
performance à la livraison et en oeuvre
ce qu'on ne fait pas aujourd'hui on
commence à le faire on a essayé de le
développer dans les différents projets
profils et autres et des outils qui
permettent de le faire
en oubliant pas que tous ces sujets sont
complexifiés par le fait que la plupart
des rénovations sont aussi occupées et
donc ça ne permet pas de faire une
révélation globale il faut faire souvent
par l'eau et avec un sujet en site
occupé et donc aussi une capacité
d'endettement des ménages à ne pas
pouvoir tout faire donc ça pose des
questions qui sont très structurantes
mais la première pour moi reste celle de
la mise en œuvre et donc de la capacité
de production c'est un sujet que on a
travaillé depuis fort longtemps sans
beaucoup de succès par rapport à
l'écoute qui peut y avoir sur ces et
j'ai écouté les différents acteurs
il n'en n'ont pas beaucoup parlé
[Musique]
malheureusement ça a une vraie
difficulté pour passer dans un tissu qui
est quand même assez peu technique au
sens numérique ce sont des TPE PME qui
ont une vraie difficulté à s'approprier
bon les ingénieristes et évidemment les
groupes ti ou l'entreprise générale
d'une certaine taille arrive à le faire
mais c'est un véritable
néanmoins c'était une innovation majeure
qui a permis à mon avis de faire en
sorte qu'aujourd'hui bon ces fameux
outils de connaître les bases de données
nationales sont une base très robuste
qui nous permet de savoir où on part et
qu'est-ce qu'on doit faire et après de
le suivre les autres innovations sur les
produits et là je reviens sur le thème
est-ce que les startups je dirais il y a
presque une forme d'oxymore entre la
question massification et startup
puisque une Chine et une start-up et une
Chine ce sont des gens qui sont très
volontaires sur un sujet ils sont de
petites dimensions il y a toujours une
industrie qui veille à l'innovation qui
est produite par ces startups et qui
très rapidement c'est acheter les
technologies ou les entreprises ou
investir dans les capitaux qu'il faut
pour les faire grossir et on se rend
compte qu'aujourd'hui dans l'innovation
on a énormément alors là nous on les a
vécu comme tel à la fois sur la partie
numérique les constats un peu de
maquette numérique un peu de suivi des
usages des sujets sur la qualité de
l'air et beaucoup je suis sur les
matériaux avec un vrai sujet aujourd'hui
c'est puisqu'il est sorti
la problématique environnementale et
recyclage des matériaux un peu réemploi
on a tout un ensemble d'acteurs qui en
termes de start-up investissent dans des
nouveaux matériaux de tout type et c'est
une vraie question parce que c'est
matériaux il faudra tous les tester
notamment sur les problématiques
principalement sanitaire pour ne pas se
retrouver avec les problématiques de
l'amiante comme on les a eu dans ce sens
et donc ces startups là elles ont
souvent appris une taille critique qui
n'arrive pas à passer à la et la
problématique que l'on a c'est une
volonté souvent de se tourner vers des
gisements très locaux et les gisements
locaux ne sont pas aptes à servir à une
logique de massification d'abord on a ni
le gisement ni la main d'oeuvre formée
pour pouvoir arriver à porter le volume
qu'il y aura à faire rénovation donc ça
repose à une question de
l'industrialisation que les fédérations
n'aiment pas aborder dans ce sens-là et
il n'y a jamais eu dans le terme
industrialisation
une capacité à dire qu'on va se
substituer aux acteurs qui font la mise
en oeuvre actuellement c'est un
accompagnement et c'est véritablement
quelque chose qui doit être fait
ensemble les artisans ont des
compétences et un véritable intérêt sur
des actes particuliers il y aurait un
intérêt particulier avant une
industrialisation notamment sur les
façade les ite les inondations
thermiques par l'extérieur par exemple
sur les toitures il y a tout un tas de
solutions qui ont été développées
notamment par Monier ou autre à d'autres
époques qui étaient des toitures
complètes qu'on remplace et qui c'est
quand même 25% des déperditions et qui
remplacé one shot parce qu'elle est
construite offsite donc il y a des
solutions mais il peine à trouver je
dirais leur marché puisqu'on est dans un
système où on le voit quand même tous
les acteurs essaient de préserver le
système dans lequel ils sont
et tant qu'on n'aura pas un driver qui
va quand même pousser vers l'idée que on
peut toujours dire que les solutions
actuelles nous amèneront un jour
peut-être non je pense qu'il faut
réellement ce qu'on appelait au sens de
l'encre des games c'est-à-dire d'arriver
à définir bon là il y a un vrai sujet
est-ce que l'industrialisation elle
passe par aussi des solutions type qui
sont définies mais qui vont être
accompagnés au niveau des aides mais pas
les autres parce que ça ce sont des
choix aujourd'hui au sens industriel
vous avez une foutu de pompe à chaleur
qui ont d'ailleurs été subventionnés à
l'époque en termes de R&D par les études
de l'ADEME et autres on n'a jamais eu de
choix industriels en disant mais le prix
d'une pompe à chaleur c'est et le niveau
de prix d'achat sera à tel niveau tout
au dessus ne sera pas pris en compte
pour les aides ou ainsi de suite donc ce
sujet n'est pas réellement traité et il
y a donc dans la logique énergétique de
la rénovation on regarde que la partie
énergie au sens de la consommation
d'énergie on ne voit pas assez les
impacts comme je disais qui sont les
collatéraux qui vont être sur le
parce qu'en fait comme on a très bien
dit je ne sais plus qui ont fait une
rénovation certes pour l'économie
d'énergie mais c'est pas l'économie
d'énergie en tant que tel en termes de
cash iN ou OUT qu'on va récupérer c'est
quand même tout un système sur lequel on
rentre peut-être il y a un geste citoyen
dans l'idée qu'on va préserver pour les
enfants ainsi de suite mais il y a aussi
une notion de confort et ce sujet qui a
été renforcé par la problématique du
covid aussi est réellement sorti mais il
n'est pas encore pris en compte par
toutes les solutions technologiques qui
devront être développées et aujourd'hui
on assiste donc à des innovations qui
sont à la fois très
sectorielle bien sûr des thèmes alors
des matériaux le numérique
les systèmes de gestion puisque on a
quelques fois la gestion de chantier par
exemple qui est un vrai sujet puisque
c'est souvent une vraie difficulté entre
les acteurs qui interviennent pour qu'on
ait un lit management des chantiers et
réduire les coûts beaucoup de startups
se sont lancés dans ces sujets là mais
elles auront une vraie difficulté à
passer à l'échelle supérieure donc pour
moi le premier suivi de la notification
reste celui de la capsule à produire qui
aujourd'hui n'est pas d'abordé et tous
nos acteurs y compris industriels je
refais je recite un peu nos voisins qui
a dit que Kamel l'industrialisation
serait dehors de 15% je pense je pense
qu'il faut que il faut viser beaucoup
plus et notamment à travers des produits
qui sont réellement travailler entre
industriels pour leur intégrabilité et
la performance du système
que dire après tout cela
premier point effectivement je pense que
la problématique du manque de
professionnelle qu'on évoque là-dessus
provient aussi d'une d'un manque de
requestionnement des méthodes
formation et besoins en formation
je vais prendre l'exemple d'un menuisier
vous mettez un menuisier dans un CFA ou
dans une école etc de menuiserie on va
la prendre à construire une fenêtre on
va la prendre à construire une porte etc
etc
sauf que ce sont des produits
aujourd'hui qui sont pour majorité
industrialisés
et donc nous ce qu'on essaye de faire et
moi ce que je défends aussi c'est plutôt
de se dire mais c'est quel geste dont
j'ai besoin et je pense qu'aujourd'hui
si on veut amener plus de personnes et
rapidement dans nos métiers c'est aussi
de considérer qu'un chef de chantier est
peut-être menuisier maîtrise l'ensemble
des compétences de la menuiserie mais
qu'il nous faut des bons poseurs de
fenêtres
d'accord qui ont cette spécialité
puisque les produits deviennent plus
techno mais il faut aussi des personnes
capables de les poser et que cette
personne là une vraie compétence
valorisable et sur cette formation geste
j'ai en mémoire chose c'est que lorsque
j'étais dans l'entreprise j'adorais
faire poser les appareillages par des
gens qui venaient de l'horlogerie les
appareillages électriques
il y avait pas meilleur que pour le
faire d'accord mes électriciens eux
étaient parfaits pour faire les armoires
électriques tout ce qui était
infrastructures etc mais la pose de
l'appareillage le dernier geste qui fait
la décoration de cetera je préférais
utiliser ces gens-là donc tout ça pour
dire que je pense que si on veut
répondre aussi à ce besoin
de d'avoir plus de professionnels avec
nous il faut aussi accepter d'avoir des
professionnels qui ont peut-être plus de
tâches
précises mais dans lesquelles on pourra
les considérer comme des spécialistes
d'accord et ça je pense que c'est pour
moi quelque chose aussi qui est très
important alors c'est vrai que tout à
l'heure je vous parlais de dire dans la
rénovation il faut des personnes qui
pensent globales et là je vous dis je
réduis à la tâche minimum mais je pense
qu'il faut de tout justement il faut le
chef de chantier celui qui va animer
tout ça qui est cette vision globale et
qui avec lui et des bons professionnels
l'industrie pour se développer à bien eu
des postes à l'époque fort etc c'était
décomposé chaque geste alors j'en arrive
pas là mais déposer ça le geste pour que
chaque geste soit performant d'accord et
que chacun se sente performant de ce
qu'il fait donc je pense que ça c'est
quelque chose qui est pour moi très
important et qu'il faut faire évoluer la
formation on voit lorsqu'on travaille
avec des organismes de formation pour
faire évoluer les les éléments
constituant la formation bon nous est
passé par des des choses qu'ils
appellent aujourd'hui des mineurs
c'est-à-dire le programme ils font le
programme global de formation et en plus
il va rajouter les formations donc on a
besoin aujourd'hui
d'accord sur certains gestes sur l'usage
de certains produits donc ça c'est
quelque chose d'important sur la notion
d'évolution effectivement des des
produits et on parle énormément de
biosourcés on parle beaucoup de ces
choses
je crois qu'aussi là-dessus il y a il y
a un intérêt c'est qu'il faut se dire
que si c'est biosaucé c'est que ça sert
aussi à quelque chose d'autre que la
filière bâtiment et qu'il faut
impérativement avant que ces produits
soient mis en oeuvre qu'on s'assure bien
qu'il n'y ait pas une déstabilisation de
la filière d'origine du produit
la paille je vais pas me faire des amis
mais on peut se poser la question de
savoir est-ce que nous le ressources
Pike qu'il faudrait sur le chanvre par
exemple on peut se poser la question
mais elle est différente puisque le
chanvre est une plante et ce qu'on va
utiliser pour faire des assiettes etc
c'est une partie de la plante qui
n'était pas utilisée pour d'autres
vecteurs de d'usage donc on a tout ça
qui est pour moi hyper important aussi
pour ce que je vais appeler augmenter
l'acceptabilité de toute cette
méthode et également donner une chance à
tous ces produits vous parliez tout à
l'heure de la difficulté de faire
reconnaître les produits et l'évolution
je pense que la filière avait une bonne
leçon là-dessus puisque ils ont réussi à
avoir des des ATEX des avis techniques
etc très rapidement y compris sur de la
paillachée je crois que ça a été quatre
mois un peu plus de quatre mois pour
obtenir latex paillaché je suis bien
placé parce que c'est accompagné donc si
je peux le dire mais voilà et je pense
réellement qu'on peut faire des choses
intéressantes mais à la caution que tout
le monde se mobilise autour de ça
alors moi aussi c'est ce quand je
parlais tout à l'heure de la partie
innovation pour en faire quelque chose
d'innovation performante et économique
etc je pense que pour moi dans
l'évolution de l'évolution il y a quoi
il y a d'ailleurs celui qui a l'idée
c'est ce que je vous disais tout à
l'heure il y a ensuite une fois que son
idée elle est validée machin ça faut
qu'on lui donne la possibilité de la
démontrer parce qu'en France on y croit
que ce qu'on envoie donc faut aussi lui
donner la capacité et pour moi c'est là
aussi où je pense que plutôt que d'aider
uniquement la recherche développement
faut aussi aider à prouver la phase
préaldustrialisation l'accompagner
et je crois beaucoup dans cette phase là
ce besoin là et puis ensuite c'est le
partager c'est à faire en connaître à
tout le monde et je pense que là
aujourd'hui tout le monde a bien compris
enfin beaucoup de gens aujourd'hui ont
bien compris que si ils ont une idée qui
veulent la garder pour le et qui veulent
elles se développera pas donc il y a
besoin de ce partage de l'innovation et
de l'innovation
je suis intimement persuadé de cela et
même un moment quand j'étais un peu
quand je suis un peu provocateur je dis
souvent qu'on ferait mieux d'aider à
utiliser un produit plutôt que des le
développer puisque j'ai toujours
constaté quelque chose c'est que
lorsqu'il y avait un débouché économique
la partie industrielle la partie
entreprise star était capable de
développer le produit à partir du moment
qu'on lui garantissait un débouché j'ai
connu à une époque un développement de
voitures électriques je citerai pas
voilà d'accord on a financé énormément
de développement de véhicules sauf que
le véhicule quand il a sorti il est
sorti pour le prédicaliser il aurait
fallu des financements
il y a pas eu de financement de prêt à
jusqu'à
finaliser alors que si on avait financé
la pré-industrialisation je suis
persuadé qu'on a trouvé les acteurs
capables de financer une bonne partie de
la recherche donc là aussi je pense que
lorsqu'on veut faire des innovations il
faut pas s'arrêter à considérer qu'on a
accompagné l'innovation mais il faut
l'accompagner jusqu'à la culture de la
prod à partir de là après elle
fonctionne puisque on est bien d'accord
à une réduction de coûts pour arriver à
avoir des coûts compétitifs dans le mode
y compris construction et bien il faut
l'industrialiser il faut les prouver et
ça c'est important et cette phase là
écoute de l'argent et c'est un problème
donc voilà un petit peu par rapport à
ces sujets et puis effectivement je
crois que faut quand même qu'on entre
dans dans l'air de l'économie circulaire
de la du recyclage etc et je pense que
là il y a toute une fille à construire
elle se construit un peu aujourd'hui
mais il y a encore beaucoup de travail à
faire pour que effectivement
et je pense que le milieu de la
rénovation est un milieu justement qui
peut permettre du réemploi d'accord
puisque il est cohérent de faire adapter
des produits par rapport à cela et dans
le contexte
et que effectivement je pense que cette
capacité qu'on doit avoir et cette
préoccupation qu'on va avoir de
l'économie circulaire du réemploi est un
outil aussi qui peut être un vecteur qui
peut être largement aidé par tout ce
qu'on a dit tout à l'heure puisqu'on
parle beaucoup de numérisation pour
faire des bâtiments neufs mais il va
falloir aussi bien pour comprendre que
la numérisation peut nous permettre de
mieux comprendre un bâtiment pour
pouvoir intégrer des éléments et
raisonner parallèlement sur ce bâtiment
là et de trouver un élément qui puisse
correspondre à un besoin qu'il soit à 5
km pour 25 ou à 50 km par le numérique
on doit pouvoir y arriver voilà un petit
peu le témoignage complémentaire de
terrain que je pourrais apporter
du coup
c'est intéressant de parler de
l'innovation et
et c'est vrai que il y a des choses qui
qui peuvent permettre
d'améliorer et il y a des choses qui
peuvent permettre de faire et c'est vrai
qu'il faut à la fois travailler sur les
deux mais c'est vrai qu'il faut pas
oublier qu'il y a des choses qui
existent des matériaux qui existent qui
sont connus depuis très longtemps des
manières de faire qui existent qui sont
connues depuis très longtemps aussi et
donc il faut aussi il faut à la fois
travailler sur des choses pour améliorer
le confort d'été des choses pour
améliorer le côté biosourcé
et mais il faut essayer de lever les
premiers freins qui font que il y a pas
suffisamment de gens qui font les
travaux
et moi je pense qu'il y a les étapes
importantes qui ont été franchis sur le
DPE et l'étiquette énergie je crois que
ça c'est quand même je sais pas si on
peut parler d'une innovation mais c'est
quand même quelque chose qui est
maintenant connu de tout le monde et ça
c'est une base sur laquelle il faut je
pense s'appuyer et
chaque fois qu'il va y avoir quelque
chose pour faire évoluer le
bâtiment quand on parle parfois de
passeport rénovation énergétique je
pense qu'il faut essayer de tout
raccrocher quand même à ça qui est il y
a le DPE qui est déjà connu ça sert à
rien d'inventer des noms ou des
nouvelles échelles ou trop de formes
indifférents peut-être essayer de
capitaliser au maximum sur celui-là qui
qui commence voilà maintenant à être
vraiment connu après il y a les
dispositifs de subventions
les certificats économie d'énergie et
m'imprime rénove
j'ai l'impression que ça commence à être
de plus en plus connu aussi et moi je
pense qu'il faut aussi continuer dans
cette direction pour éviter de de trop
souvent changer parce que en me disant
sur la rénovation énergétique globale il
y en a eu des changements voilà c'est
c'est vraiment énormément d'efforts
énormément de temps de formation pour
pour quelque chose qui au final change
pas grand chose en vrai en vrai il y a
pas des énormes changements mais c'est
mais c'est juste que c'est contraignant
il faut modifier il faut expliquer
parfois il y a des dossiers qui sont
lancés du coup ils peuvent pas être
concrétisés comme ça c'est vraiment
c'est il faut vraiment le dire même si
tout le monde le sait mais c'est
vraiment très très fréquent
je sais pas si le coup de tous ces
changements
il est pas supérieur à l'économie
potentielle qui va être faite sur le
dispositif maintenant on le voit le
plafonner à 7500 euros au lieu de 10000
euros des choses comme ça
ça c'est quand même un vrai sujet mais
par contre je suis je pense que ces
aides sont vraiment importantes pour les
particuliers c'est ça qui leur permet de
lancer les travaux le fait qu'elles
arrivent en remise des devis que les
particuliers alors c'est pas toujours le
cas mais de plus en plus les entreprises
font en sorte que les aides viennent en
déduction des devis pour pas qu'ils
aient avancés cet argent ça je pense que
c'est vraiment important nous on l'a vu
sur des milliers de personnes qui ont
fait des projets parce que ils veulent
du coup financer le reste à charge mais
ils auraient pas pu tout financer ou
avancer les subventions donc ça c'est
quand même un vrai plus voilà qui il
faut souligner après il y a le sujet de
l'accompagnateur rénovant donc
c'est vrai que c'est difficile de d'y
voir 100% clair sur le sujet même si moi
je participais assister aux différentes
présentations du dispositif donc moi je
suis plutôt pour le principe de
l'accompagnateur Renov et l'idée que
quelqu'un puisse
accompagner le particulier qui s'est pas
par quel bout démarrer je pense que
c'est une bonne chose après on peut
dissocier la partie bilan énergétique
estimation des subventions estimations
du coup aussi estimation pas de vie
estimation et la partie accompagnement
du maître d'ouvrage sur le volet travaux
il y a un peu Lamont et puis il y a tout
au long du sachant que cet
accompagnement ça va pas être de la
maîtrise d'oeuvre il y a pas forcément
une assurance de maître d'oeuvre c'est à
dire que l'accompagnateur est neuve si
jamais les travaux sont mal fait c'est
pas sa faute
ça c'est un point aussi importants c'est
pas ça responsabilité c'est la
responsabilité de l'installateur
contrairement d'ailleurs au contractant
général s'il y a un problème sur
l'installation du particulier on se
retourne vers le contractant général
c'est sa faute et donc lui
éventuellement pourra se retourner
contre l'installateur mais ça c'est un
point intéressant quand même sur le
volet assurantiel
par rapport aux travaux mais sur le
principe de l'accompagnateur et neuve
ça existe déjà sur certains lots
pour certains revenus
ça rajoute c'est vrai des étapes mais il
me semble que c'est quelque chose qui
est important
tous les acteurs du bâtiment ne seront
pas des contractants généraux donc que
les contractants généraux puissent jouer
ce rôle je pense que c'est important
mais il y aura quand même une grande
majorité des travaux qui seront réalisés
par des installateurs sur un métier en
particulier et il y aura besoin
je crois d'accompagnateurs et 9 par
contre il faut probablement pas se
précipiter parce que les choses semblent
pas forcément trop clair pour tout le
monde il y a des échéances qui arrivent
pour le mois de septembre
voilà avoir si si c'est toujours
difficile en cours d'année ou en fin
d'année pour une profession d'accueillir
des changements s'ils n'ont pas été
suffisamment préparés
et un autre point que je voulais mettre
en avant c'est le point du RGE donc sur
le RGE il y a peu de société qui ont la
qualification RGE pour bénéficier des
pour permettre d'obtenir les subventions
il faut que l'entreprise qui installe
soit RGE
donc parfois on entend il faut durcir le
dispositif pour obtenir la qualification
de RGE
et est-ce qu'il y a pas un paradoxe
entre le fait de durcir alors qu'il y en
a déjà peu et parfois on dit c'est trop
facile d'avoir le RGE
mais d'autres fois il y a des
installateurs qui moi j'ai pas besoin du
RGE je préfère baisser un tout petit peu
le prix et comme ça j'ai pas à faire une
formation à renouveler chaque année
moi je pense que le RGE aujourd'hui il
est connu du grand public il faut
capitaliser dessus mais je le sentiment
que ça serait peut-être bien de l'ouvrir
encore plus d'essayer de faire rentrer
les installateurs en levant peut-être de
la contrainte pour que il soit RGE et
qu'il soit prêt alimenté en information
en formation qui est des échanges qui ne
vraie communauté de RGE qui se crée et
que et que les gens plutôt que de faire
des travaux qui sont pas
éligibles aux subventions mais face des
travaux éligibles au subjon donc en tout
cas je pense qu'il y a un sujet sur le
fait qu'il faut que les installateurs
deviennent RGE se forment et qu'il y en
ait de plus en plus parce que comme
disait
des personnes avant il faut suffisamment
d'installateurs pour atteindre les
objectifs et
voilà et capitaliser sur ça et l'ouvrir
au maximum je pense que ça serait
important et puis pour aller jusqu'à la
fin des travaux et répondre à la
question par rapport aux contractant
général la campagnateur rénove
il y a ensuite le contrôle voilà parce
que autant
[Musique]
j'ai l'impression que un Contractant
Général ensemblier il va être bien placé
pour faire le bilan énergétique réaliser
les travaux autant c'est intéressant de
contrôler si ces travaux ils ont été
bien fait et donc là c'est vrai que le
contrôle systématique qu'on peut avoir
dans le cadre par exemple de la fiche
bar à un th164 qui est le C2E sur la
rénovation énergétique globale c'est un
contrôle systématique post travaux ça me
semble des choses intéressantes de voilà
d'avoir des contrôles
à la fin des travaux et que les
organismes de contrôle eux-mêmes mais et
des certifications lourdes qui soient
eux-mêmes contrôlés pour que ce soit
fait sérieusement mais
je pense que renforcer les contrôles et
les contrôles des contrôleurs c'est un
vrai sujet et ça ça permettra de
s'assurer que les travaux sont bien
faits parce qu'ils finissent qu'on veut
c'est qu'il y a des travaux qui soient
fait chez les gens et qui soient bien
fait
non après qu'il soit fait par un
ensemble lié ou qui soit fait par
plusieurs installateurs peu importe ou
par des matériaux
voilà ce qu'il faut c'est qu'il y a la
performance énergétique et que surtout
ce soit bien fait pour pas qu'ils
décimisent derrière ou qui est des
problématiques voilà donc le sujet du
contrôle me semble dernier sujet
important
merci est-ce que quelqu'un aurait
quelque chose à rajouter Sabine oui
juste une petite question alors en fait
c'est vrai que je m'intéresse beaucoup
aux questions de patrimoine
donc le patrimoine en fait qui a une
valeur architecturale ou historique le
bâti qui différencie finalement nos
régions et qui qui en font leur
attractivité c'est vrai qu'en ce moment
avec la question du DPE qui est devenue
obligatoire pour les bailleurs et
propriétaires bailleurs se posent la
question de savoir comment faire pour
concilier en fait protection du bâti
ancien et rénovation et énergétique
alors moi j'aimerais savoir si en fait
ce sujet intéresse les startups voilà si
si vous avez des choses à nous dire de
ce côté là
je vais vous répondre à une région qui
va du Limousin jusqu'au pays basque en
parlant passant par la Charente-Maritime
d'accord et lorsqu'on fait des
manifestations et lorsqu'on évoque les
problématiques de rénovation dans toutes
ces régions les abordent pas de la même
manière d'accord puisque effectivement
vous n'allez pas faire une rénovation
d'un bâtiment type basque avec ces
colombages etc etc et un bâtiment
complètement différent sur la zone de
Limoges et je pense qu'effectivement
les gens ont besoin aussi de se dire si
je fais une rénovation etc je vais
respecter mon patrimoine je vais
respecter ma région etc et c'est là où
on peut industrialiser les méthodes on
peut faire plein de choses mais si on
veut réussir aussi notre la méthode le
savoir-faire de cela il faut prendre en
compte effectivement ces disparités qui
peut y avoir entre typologie de bâtiment
et et les régionaliser entre guillemets
alors c'est toujours très difficile de
dire on va se réaliser et en même temps
trop tenir compte des apports
territoriaux ou des conditions
territoriales qui peuvent avoir mais je
n'ai pas eu une seule c'est un
témoignage que ça apporte j'ai pas eu
une seule réunion
collective des filières des structures
etc où on parlait de rénovation sans que
la problématique du respect
du patrimoine local ne soit pas posé
donc c'est une vraie problématique qui
est posée comme une condition un
prérequis à des opérations de rénovation
donc c'est plutôt rassurant d'accord
c'est juste le témoignage que vous
apportez mais je crois vraiment qu'il y
a cette volonté là et on voit bien que
de plus en plus plus on mondialise tous
les gens ont besoin de se reconnaître
dans quelque chose et cette volonté là
moi je sais que les premières réunions
qu'on a fait et pourquoi je parle du
Pays Basque parce que première fois
qu'on en a parlé on livre jamais on fera
de rénovation nous de ce type là dans le
Pays Basque parce que nos maisons sont
trop complexes etc etc ben non il faut
se faire regarder les ménages faut
regarder un petit peu ce qui se passe à
côté etc et trouver les bonnes solutions
mais c'est un prérequis si on veut y
arriver
moi je suis plutôt inquiète à cause de
la de la de la vitesse à laquelle on
nous demande de faire ses travaux moi je
suis alsacienne et chez moi par exemple
vous avez déjà des gens qui font
n'importe quoi parce qu'il faut faire
vite
pour compléter moi je peux comprendre
votre votre inquiétude et
en tant que
capteur qui réalise des rénovation
énergétiques il y a des cas où on peut
pas répondre nous on va dire désolé on
va pas répondre parce que on n'a pas la
solution technique qui va correspondre
et que et le faire ne coûterait vraiment
trop cher écouterait trop cher aussi à
celui qui doit le faire donc en fait on
a quelque part on n'a pas envie de le
faire parce que ça va nous prendre
beaucoup de temps pour le faire pour
cette personne et si jamais on devait
lui chiffrer ça lui coûterait beaucoup
trop cher donc il y a un vrai sujet
et un vrai sujet qui va passer aussi par
le la case financement de ces
spécificités qui sont pas les choses les
plus simples
il faut pas l'oublier de financement ou
alors de tolérance ou de dérogation de
dérogation peut-être
si je puisse je crois que
l'atteinte des objectifs on voit que la
fois qu'on se fixe un objectif on peut
avoir des moyens différents d'y arriver
d'accord c'est là aussi qu'il est
important de voir on a mené une
expérience vous parliez du parc ba
carbone on a voulu faire des bâtiments
des logements aux 3 C2
mais on n'a pas dit comment
on a dit l'objectif il est là
aujourd'hui il va y avoir 330 logements
neuf constructeurs différents que
appliquer des techniques différentes
pour atteindre cet objectif là et on va
contrôler à la livraison et deux ans
après la performance de ce qui a été mis
en place ça veut dire quoi ça veut dire
que on a aussi faut se le dire dans la
rénovation on a un nombre incalculable
de solutions qui sont à nos portées et
c'est la capacité à prendre la bonne
solution au cas qui est concerné pour
avoir répondre au juste besoin d'accord
et ça je crois que c'est très très
important la précipitation comme vous
lisez c'est pas ça c'est il faut être
agile industrialisé avec de l'agilité et
se dire à partir c'est la composition
qu'on va pouvoir avoir qui va permettre
de répondre aux solutions vous allez
peut-être plus pousser sur une
performance de matériel thermique sur
une habitat que vous n'aurez pas pouvoir
isoler comme vous voudriez vous allez
plus plus pousser sur ce cadre là vous
avez plus pousser sur la gestion de la
ventilation
c'est là où je pense qu'il y a des
choses à voir et vraiment garder
l'objectif avant du Moyen pas partir en
se disant on a des moyens sur étagères
et c'est parti mais bien d'essayer
d'atteindre des objectifs et d'avoir des
solutions des mixes de solutions c'est
un peu comme la mix énergétique d'accord
et bien si on considère qu'on a une
solution dans des perdus si on considère
qu'on a une mixité de solutions on
trouve la réponse
très bien merci beaucoup messieurs on
vous souhaite une bonne soirée